françois perrot qui est à toronto
premier vice-président de la banque
scotia économiste en chef bonsoir mon
sort alors est ce que l'inflation a
atteint son sommet est ce qu'on est sur
la pente descendante
de l'inflation selon vous
on l'espère mais j'admets que le rapport
d'aujourd'hui menace pas
particulièrement optimiste comme vous
l'avez noté le fait du prix de l'énergie
un gros impact sur l'inflation si ce
n'est pas surprenant mais lorsqu'on
regarde des mesures d' inflation
tendancielle donc des mesures qui exclut
les chocs les aliments ou les choses des
plus volatils on observe quand même une
augmentation au moment du mois de
juillet qui suggère qu'on n'a pas encore
son voeu le franchit le câble d'une
habitation est ce qu'on a observé ces
camps mais c'est quand même intéressant
parce que oui on est on est en baisse
sur l'ensemble de l'inflation mais
excluant l'essence le taux d'inflation
monsieur perrault est quand même plus
élevé quand je jouais donc l'inflation
et généralisé à
tout à fait tout à fait et c'est simple
la dynamique qu'on à laquelle on
s'attendait bon ça avec lé facteur
plus ou moins temporaire qui incluait
son inflation bonds le prix d'énergie
serait une certaine mesure pandémie dès
qu'ils ont affecté l'inflation dans les
derniers mois on s'attendait par compass
que les salaires l'augmentation des
salaires le retour dans les restaurants
le gâteau dans les avions que softs à
contribuer à l'inflation un peu plus de
façon un peu plus contemporaine et ça
longtemps l'obtient donc on est à un
point où il ya des évidences comme quoi
que la flambée d'inflation qu'on a
observé l'année passée où jusqu'à tout
récemment
s'amenuisent peut-être témoin quand même
des signes qui suggèrent qu'il ya quand
même beaucoup de travail à faire mais
quand même est-ce que le ralentissement
de l'économie mondiale qu'on constate
présentement pic semble vouloir se
poursuivre va créer une pression
supplémentaire à la baisse sur le prix
de l'énergie et que on peut prendre pour
acquis que l'inflation va ralentir
c'est effectivement le ciel référence de
la plupart des gens car là donc on
conseille un ralentissement économique
mondial qui a en partie
l'effet des primes à ses frères qu'on a
observés dans les narines en mai dernier
trimestre grâce à la demande globale
évidemment même des faiblesses d'énergie
salés de génération mais ça réduite
qu'une seule composante de l'inflation
c'est ça la gironde un peu partout la
même grosso modo seul composant les
facteurs domestiques comme les loyers
carrément très rapide en cas là ils vont
continuer à augmenter les frères qui
augmentent ils ont continué à augmenter
les prix des aliments qui ont également
qu'il va prendre continuellement t aussi
tout ça suggère qui a quand même pas mal
de momentum lorsqu'on exclut l'énergie
de leno calcul est ce que vous diriez
que les hausses de taux jusqu'à
maintenant ont un effet au canada
c'est un peu tôt c'est un peu toi savoir
écouter ça prend entre 18 et 24 mois dix
mois à vingt quatre mois que hong kong
observe l'impact maximum d'être
intéressant mais là on parle tellement
de hausses de taux de touche qui
maintenant est ce que ça vient pas nous
jouer dans le mental un peu là
est un peu un peu je pense que ça nous
inquiète davantage sur la société
sioniste parce qu'on observe à côté une
augmentation du coût de la vie et
l'importance de l'eau côté une
augmentation des taux d'intérêts s'agit
bien les capacités nasser des ménages
déclarent par contre l'augmentation tout
ralenti la croissance on sait on le voit
la marche et du mobilier c'est très
évident est-ce que ça a eu un impact sur
les créations à date probablement pas
mais il reste qu'on peut faire
l'argument que dans le contexte du
marché du logement malgré l'échec le
prix baissent
l'augmentation du taux fait sans doute
augmenter les loyers et les loyers se
sont rendus directement dans la mesure
d'inflation donc à la limite la rotation
les toucans l'observa date contribuer
peut-être même un peu plus sa réputation
que la situation où les toreros
augmenter encore prochaine annonce de la
banque du canada le 7 septembre où
prévoyaient une nouvelle hausse tout le
monde prévoit une hausse supplémentaire
au mode 7 ans au moins au mois de
septembre de convier
au moins 500 points de base on ne serait
pas surpris voire 75 points de base et
encore pas mal de travail à faire
l'inflation demeure un problème le
gouverneur lundi qui à plusieurs
reprises l'inflation demeure la
problématique
ils sont prêts à agir de façon très
agressive il est en fête avec 100 points
de base de la décision on ne serait pas
surpris qu'ils agissent avec un peu
moins de là mais quand même pas mal de
là à la prochaine rencontre qu'est ce
que la banque centrale veut voir en ce
moment pour mettre fin à sa hausse de
taux
écoutez la seule chose qui devrait
décider si l'inflation la croissance
économique et récession ou non qui
ralentissement économique ou non bon
c'est des choses qui sont indications de
narration si on veut mais l'inflation
pèse même tellement élevé tellement loin
la cible à ben qui ont pas vraiment un
choix le cas de foxy sur l'inflation est
un peu las de
filtrer sur les autres formations
qu'elles ''s'en aurait peut-être porte
attention en partie mais à quel niveau
là on est rendu on vient leur baisse à
7,6 qu'on verra le prochain mois jusqu'à
quel niveau faut que ça baisse donne
pour que la banque du canada 10 parfait
le mouvement est bien enclenché on n'a
plus besoin d'augmenter les taux
je pense qu'ils ont ce qu'ici recherche
c'est ce qu'on recherche mais aussi dans
nos prévisions sur un loyer de
l'évidence que le cycle inflationniste
en rien changé donc on a atteint son
sommet que ce soit en juillet un mois
d'août est le mois de septembre qui est
des évidences comme quoi bon là
l'inflation commence à diminuer et
s'assemblent et persistants çà semble
être bien soutenu si on se retrouve dans
cette situation alors je pense quand
même beaucoup beaucoup de pression sur
la banque elle voir beaucoup plus de
confort à dealer l'inflation demeure
trop élevé mais sur la bonne piste
bien on continue de suisse avec beaucoup
d'intérêt tous les jours d'ailleurs jean
françois perrot merci je me sens mal
pour merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit